okay hey everyone morning welcome to CST
30 deep learning so many of you know
that deep learning these days is the
latest hottest area of computer science
or AI arguably deep learning is the
latest hottest area of you know all the
human activity maybe but this is a cost
CST 30 deep learning where we hope that
we can help you understand the state of
the art and become experts at building
and applying deep learning systems
unlike many Stanford courses this class
will be more interactive than than
others because this class we often in
the flipped classroom format where we'll
ask you to watch a lot of the videos at
home a lot of the deep learning AI
content hosted on Coursera does
preserving the classroom and discussion
section time but much deeper discussions
so to get started let me let me first
introduce our teaching team so the
co-instructors Archaean cotton guru who
had actually one of the co-creators of
the deep learning specialization the
atlanta AI content that were using in
this class and the rest of the teaching
team swathi Dube is the cost coordinator
and she has been working with me and
others on coordinating I guess CSU 30
also cs2 29 CSU generate to make all of
these classes run well and let you have
a relatively smooth you know experience
Eunice Mori is the cause adviser and
he'd also worked closely with IANA me in
creating blobby online contents that you
use and Eunice is also head ta 462 98
which some of you may also be taking and
then we have two co-head TAS or RT by
guru who's worked on machine learning
research for a long time and opposition
oi who is still traveling back I think
and also a large team of TAS that I
think about half about TAS and CS 230
had previously ta
schools and their expertise spans
everything from applying machine
learning problems in the health care or
climate learning or applying deep
learning to problems it in robotics to
problems in computational biology to
problems in so I hope that as you work
on your projects this quarter as policy
as 2:30 you'll be able to get a lot of
great advice and help and mentorship
from all of the tiers as well so the
plan for today is I was going to spend
maybe the little bit of time sharing
with you what's happening in deep
learning why you know why deep learning
is taking off and how this might affect
your careers and then in the second half
I have Ken will take over and talk a bit
more about the projects you work on in
this class and not just a final term
project but you know the little machine
translation system you build the face
recognition system you build their our
generation system you build their all of
the many pretty cool machine learning
deep learning applications I mean you
get to build throughout the course of
this quarter and also share view the the
detailed logistics for the plan for the
class ok so I think that let's see all
right I'm going to just use the
whiteboard for this part so um
you know deep learning right you know
seems like the media still can't stop
talking about it
and it turns out that a lot of the ideas
of deep learning happen around for
several decades right the basic ideas of
deep learning happen around for decades
so why is deep learning suddenly taking
off now that why is it quote coming out
of nowhere on whatever whatever people
say I think that the main reason that
deep learning has been taking off and
why you know suddenly all of you
hopefully will be that do really
powerful things with it much more
effectively than two or three years ago
is the following um for a lot of over
the last couple decades with the
digitization of society we've just
collected more and more data so for
example all of us spend a lot more time
on our computers and smart phones now
and whenever you do things on the phone
you know that creates data right and and
and what used to be represented through
pieces of paper is now much more likely
a digital record as well so you're if
you go take an x-ray as at least in the
United States less than some other kind
in developing colonies beliefs in the
United States there's much higher chance
now than your x-ray in the hospital is a
digital image rather than a physical
piece of film or if you order a new
marker right there's a much higher
chance that the fact that you order the
marker you know off a website it's now
represented as a digital record compared
to ten years ago when the state of the
global supply chain actually if you
order if you order ten thousand markers
there's a much higher chance you know
ten years ago that the fact that you
place that order was stored on a piece
of paper that someone scribbled saying a
ship ten thousand markers to Stanford
but now that's much more likely to be a
digital record and so the fact that so
many pieces of paper and our digital has
created data and for a lot of
application areas the amount of data has
sort of you know exploded over the loss
twenty years but what we found was that
if you look at more traditional learning
algorithms traditional machine learning
algorithms the performance and most of
them would Plateau
even as you feed it more and more days
so by traditional learning algorithms I
mean logistic regression support vector
machines you know maybe decision trees
develop initial details and it was as if
out all the learning algorithms didn't
know what to do of all the data you can
now feed it but what we start to define
several years ago was they between a
small neural network right it's
performance may look like that if we
train a medium neural net the ones may
look like that and if you train a very
large neural net you know the
performance kind of keeps on getting
better and better up to some usually up
to some theoretical limit called Bayes
error rate which is learned about later
this coarser a bit but performance can
never exceed 100% but sometimes
sometimes there's some seething in the
performance but also we've been able to
measure on many many problems with not
yet I think that across machine learning
and deep learning broadly I think we've
not yet hit the limits of scale and by
scale I mean the amount of data you can
throw the problem that's still useful
for the problem as well as the size of
the neural networks and I think you know
GPU computing was a large part of how we
were able to go from training small two
mediums and now training very large
neural networks and once upon a time I
think you know the first actually I
think a lot of the early work on
training neural networks on GPUs done
here at Stanford right who they're using
crew that the training neural networks
but what used to be you know one thing
one lessons we learn over and over in
computing is that what yesterday's
supercomputer is today's you know
processor on your on your SmartWatch
right and so what used to be an amount
of computation that was accessible only
to you know large research labs in
Stanford they could spend a hundred
thousand dollars on GPUs today you could
that honor on a cloud relatively
inexpensively and so the availability of
relatively large neural network training
capabilities as allow really students
really know almost everyone many people
not not many many people to have enough
access computational power to train what
are large enough nearing that where else
to drive very high levels of accuracy
for a lot of applications right and it
turns out that if you look broadly
across AI you know I think the mass
media right newspapers reporters use the
term AI I think within within academia
or within the industry you tend to say
machine learning and deep learning but
if you look broadly across AI it turns
out that AI has many many tools that's
beyond machine learning does even beyond
deep learning and if any of you take you
know CS 221 write stamp is a high class
great class you learn about a lot of
these other tools of AI but the reason
that deep learning is so valuable today
is that if you look across many of the
tools of AI and that's saying you know
there's a deep learning slash machine
learning oh and and and and again some
you know new networks and deep learning
mean almost exactly the same thing right
it's just that as you know as we start
to see deep learning rise of the last
several years we found that deep
learning was just a much more attractive
brand and so you know and so so that's
the brand that took off but if you look
at if you even take an AI class it was a
broadly across the portfolio of tools
you have an AI I think that you know
I'll often use deep learning machine
learning how sometimes also use a
probabilistic graphical model right we
should learn the button cs2 Tony also
great cause sometimes I use the planning
algorithm you know when I'm working on a
self-driving car right you need a motion
planning algorithm you need various
planning our rhythms sometimes I use a
search algorithm sometimes I use
knowledge representation it's very sick
this is one of the technologies
especially knowledge drafts
is one of the technologies that is
widely used in industry but I think
often underappreciated in academia if
you do a web search and a web search
engine pulls up a hotel and the list of
room prices and what this Wi-Fi was a
swimming pool that's actually a
knowledge graph or knowledge
representation knowledge graph but so
it's actually used by many companies
this large databases but this is that he
may be under appreciated in academia or
sometimes even game theory so if you
learn about AI there is a very large
portfolio of many different tools you
will see but what has happened over the
last several years is if you go to a
conference on probabilistic graphical
models right if this is time and this is
a performance e you see that you know
every year probably see graphical models
work a little bit better than the year
before
if you go to the u AI conference
uncertainty an AI conference maybe the
one of the leading conferences maybe the
leading one not shown on P GM's you see
there every year you know researchers
published papers that better than the
year before in the state it's the the
field is steadily marching always I'm
saying for planning if you go to Tripoli
on something you see you know a feud is
advancing social rooms are getting
better
another obsession Alvarez game better
getting Theory albums again better and
so the the field of AI marches forward
across all of these different
disciplines but the one that has taken
off you know incredibly quickly is deep
learning machine learning and I think a
lot of this progress was initially
driven by scale scale of data and scale
of computation and the fact that we can
now get tons of data during the surge on
your network and get good performance
but more recently has been also driven
by the positive feedback loop of seeing
early traction and deep learning thus
causing a lot more people to do research
and deep learning algorithms and so
there's been tons of algorithmic
innovation in deep learning in the last
several years and you hear a lot about
algorithms that were you know relatively
recently invented
to sauce as well right and so really I
think that initially the twin forces of
a scale of data scale computation but
now the triple forces have also a lot of
algorithmic innovation and massive
investment is continuing to make deep
learning make tremendous progress and so
in CST 30 we kind of have you know I I
think two main goals the first is to
have you become expert in the deep
learning algorithms have you have you
learned the city arts have you have you
have you have deep technical knowledge
on the save outs and deep learning and
second is to give you the know how to
apply these algorithms to whatever
problems you want to work on so one of
the things I've learned so I think you
know actually some some of you guys know
my history right so you know birthed at
Stanford for a long time then um started
as leading the Google brain team which
did law projects at Google and I think
the Google brain teams you know built
from scratch was arguably the leading
force for helping Google go from what
was already a great internet company
into today a great AI company and then
there's something some that I do in
China
oh it's Chinese hey cause in China which
kind of helped I do go from also what
was already a great company into today
you know many people say China's
greatest AI company and I think through
work on many projects at Google many
friends if I do and now leading landing
AI are helping many companies on many
projects and running around to different
companies and see many different machine
learning projects they have I think I've
been fortunate to learn a lot of lessons
not just about the technical aspects of
machine learning but about the practical
know-how has fangs the Machine your name
and if you and and I think that what you
can learn from you know the internet or
from purely academic sources or from
reading research papers is a lot of the
technical aspects of machine learning
and deep learning
but there are a lot of other practical
aspects of how to get these algorithms
to work that I actually do not know of
any other academic course that that kind
of goes into great deaf teaching rates
there might be one but I'm I'm not sure
but one of the things that we hope to do
in this class is to not just give you
the tools but also giving know-how on
how to make it work right and I think
you know I should spend a lot of time
thinking about
so actually late last night I actually
stayed that very late last night meeting
this new book by um Jon osterhaus on a
software architecture right and I think
that there's a huge difference between
you know a junior software engineer and
a senior software engineer maybe
everyone understands the c-plus paused
in the Python in the Java syntax yeah
you can get that from promote from you
just figure out hey this is how c-plus
this works inside job where else is how
Python numpy works but it's often the
high level judgment decisions of how the
architecture system what abstractions do
you use how do you define interfaces
that defines the difference between a
really good software engineer versus you
know a less experienced software
engineer it's not understanding c-plus
or syntax and I think in the same way
today there are lots of ways for you to
learn the technical tools of machine
learning and deep learning and you will
learn that in this class you know you
learn how to train a neural network you
learn the latest optimization algorithms
you understand deeply what the content
is whether recurrent neural network
whereas when lsdm is you you understand
what intention mod allows you you learn
all of these things in great detail your
work impression could be vision
nationally entrusting speech and so on
but I think one other thing that is
relatively unique to this class and to
that I guess the the things you see on
the defender AI course are websites as
what's the things with doing cause is
trying to give you the practical
know-how so that when you're building a
machine learning system you can be very
efficient in deciding things like should
you collect more data or not right and
the answer is not always yes I think I
think um with
I think that many of us try to convey
the message that having more data is
good right and that's actually more data
pretty much never hurts but I think the
message of big data has also been
overhyped and sometimes it's actually
not worth your while to couldn't collect
more data right but so when you're
working a machine learning project and
if you are either doing it by yourself
or leading a team your ability to make a
good judgment decision about should just
spend another week collecting more data
or should you spend another week
searching for Hyper parameters or tuning
parameters your own network that's the
type of decision that if you make it
correctly can easily make your team 2x
or 3x or maybe 10x more efficient and so
one thing we hope to do in this class is
more systematically imparts to you this
this type of knowledge right and so I
think even today I you know actually I
actually visited lots of machine
learning teams around Silicon Valley
around we're on the cusp you what
they're doing and you know recently I
visited a company that had a team of 30
people trying to build a learning
algorithm and the team about 30 people
was working on learning out run for
about three months right and and they
had not yet managed to get it to work so
they're basically you know like you know
not succeeded after three months one of
my colleagues took the data set oh yeah
can your broadcasting don't say anything
bad alright so one of my colleagues took
the data set home and spend one weekend
working on what's he doing now and and
and one of my colleagues working on this
problem in one long weekend here at Sun
over long weekend for three days was
able to build a machine learning system
that outperform what this group of 30
people have been able to do after about
three months so was that desica oh no
that's more than a tengas difference and
right and and a lot of the differences
between the great machine learning teams
versus less experienced ones is actually
not just do you know how to you know
implement it's not just you know how to
implement and LST em right in intensive
though or carrots or whatever you have
to know that but there's actually other
things as well and I think Ken and I and
the teaching team are looking forward
trying to systematically impart to you a
lot of this know-how so that when
hopefully someday what you're leading a
team of machine learning engineers or
deep learning engineers that you could
help direct the team's efforts more
efficiently and oh actually if any we're
interested one of the things happen
actually how many of you have heard of
machine learning yearning machine
learning yearning Wow almost none of you
okay interesting um so this is a if this
is your first machine learning class
this may be too advanced for you but if
you've had a little bit of other machine
learning background machine learning
yearning is a booklet being right did
I've been I've been working on its
slowing draw form but if any of you want
to but machine learning yearning is my
attempt to try to turn gather best
principles the turning machine learning
from a black art into systematic
engineer discipline and so if you go to
this website you know this website will
send you actually I just finished the
last just finished the whole draft last
weekend and so email allowing students
if you want a copy go to the website and
enter your email address now make sure
that you know when we send out the book
actually might be later today not sure
that well then you get a copy of the
book drop this wall I tend to write
books and then just post them on the
internet for free so you could but this
here was just email them them out to
people so you can you can you can get it
if you go to the web site and I think
this will and I think this calls to
talking all about lot of principles of
machine learning urine II but give you
much more practice as well then they're
just reading a book might um so
let's see okay so um Jen will give a
greater overview of what we'll cover in
this class but one of the principles
have learned as well is that you know it
so I think I'm actually some of you know
my background right is a co-founder
Coursera was initially for a long time
so spent a long time really thinking a
lot about education and I think cs2 30
represents you know Keon and mine are
teaching teens really best attempt to
deliver a great on-campus deep learning
course and so and so the format of this
class is what's called a flipped
classroom class and what that means is
that so you know and I think I've taught
on SCPD for a long time right for many
many years I guess and I found it even
for classes like CST to nine or other
Stanford courses often students end up
you know watching videos at home and and
I think with the flipped classroom what
we realized was if many students are
watching videos of these lectures at
home anyway why don't we spend a lot of
effort to produce higher quality videos
that you can watch then a more time
efficient for you to watch at home and
so our team created videos DVR I created
you know kind of the best videos we knew
how to create on deep learning there are
now hosted on Coursera and so with I
actually think that will be quite time
efficient for you to watch those videos
do the online program exercises do the
online quizzes and what that does is it
preserves the class time both the weekly
sessions that we meet right here on
Wednesdays as well as the TA discussion
sections on Fridays for much deeper
interactions and for much deeper
discussions and so the format of the
class is that we ask you to you know do
the online content created by the Avaya
host on Coursera
then in class both the meetings with
enemy Anakin and I will split these
sessions roughly 50/50 as was for the
deeper small group discussion sections
you have for the TAS that lets you spend
much more time interacting with the TAS
interacting with knme and going deeper
into the material then just then the
then the then the then the online
content by yourself and that will also
give us more opportunities to give you
advanced material that goes beyond was
hosted online as well as give you
additional practice with these concepts
right and so let's see yeah and so um I
was a finish up with two more files and
now I hand it over to Karen I think you
know machine learning deep learning AI
whatever is changing a lot of industries
right IIIi think you know I think AI is
the new electricity much as the rise of
electricity about 100 years ago starting
in the United States transform every
industry really you know the rise of HST
transform agriculture because finally we
have refrigeration right that transform
agriculture a transform healthcare
imagine going to a hospital today
there's no electricity or how do you how
do you even do that right
computers medical devices have even run
a healthcare system with transform
communications through telecom through
the Telegraph initiative and now so much
the communications really needs
electricity but electricity transform
every major industry and I think machine
learning and deep learning has reached a
level of maturity where we see a
surprisingly clear path for it to also
transform pretty much every industry and
I hope that through this class after
these next ten weeks that all of you
will be well qualified to go into these
different industries and help transform
them as well and I think you know after
this class I hope that you'll be well
qualified to like get a job and some of
the big shiny
tech companies that have large AIT
I think a lot of the most exciting work
to be done today still is to go into the
less shiny industries that do not yet
have AI machine learning yet and to take
it to those areas actually underway in
us chatting with a student that works in
cosmology who was commenting was that
you know who was it so oh at the back I
was commenting the cosmology needs more
machine learning right and and then
maybe he will be the one to take a lot
of the ideas or deep learning into
cosmology because I think even outside
the shiny tech areas like and then maybe
since I helped play around there AI
transmission of two large research
companies I'm like done transforming
internet search companies and I think
that but I think and I think it's great
that we have those great AI teams like
Google grain I do AI grew other large
tech companies are great a I teams I
think that's wonderful I think a lot of
the important work to be done now how
many of you will do is to take AI to
health care taking out the competition
ology taking out to civil energy intake
Anatomy country I think all of this is
worth doing just like electricity didn't
have one color app it's useful for a lot
of things and I think many of you will
go out after this cause and execute many
exciting projects both in tech companies
and in you know other areas that that
like cosmology right or other areas they
were not traditionally considered CAS
areas um so just wrap up with a to lost
thoughts I think that one of the things
that excites me these days is on hoping
you know I always share view one of the
lessons I learned right watching the
rise of AI in multiple companies and
smell a long time thinking about you
know what is it that makes a great AI
company and one of the lessons I learned
was really a hearing Jeff Bezos speak
about what is it that makes for an
Internet company right and I think a lot
of lessons that we learn with the rise
of the Internet will be useful you know
an internet was maybe one of the last
major technology ways of disruption and
just as there's a great time to start
working on the Internet maybe 20 years
ago I think today is a great time
start working on a iot of learning and
so sir wait to turn on the lights on
this side as well do I do I control that
okay thank you okay so so I want to show
you one of the lessons either and really
spend a lot of time trying to understand
the rise of the internet because I think
we useful to many of you as you navigate
the rise of machine learning AI in your
upcoming careers as well which is um one
of the lessons I learned was it can take
your favorite shopping mall and build a
website for the shopping mall that does
not turn your shopping mall into an
Internet company right so you know like
my wife like Stanford Shopping Center
and I and Stanford Shopping has a
website but even if you know a great
shopping mall sell stuff on the website
there's a huge difference between a
shopping mall with a website compared to
true internet comfy like an Amazon so
what's the difference about five six six
six seven years ago I was chatting with
the CEO of a very large American
retailer and at that time he and the CIO
were saying to me they're saying look
Andrew we have a website we sell things
on the website amazon has a website
Amazon sells things on the website is
the same thing but of course it's not
and today this peculiar large American
retailers you know future existence is
actually a little bit in question Poggi
partly because of Amazon so one of the
lessons I learned really very influenced
by Jeff Bezos is that what defines the
Internet company is not just whether you
have a website instead it is have you
organized your team or your company to
do the things that the internet lets you
do really well for example internet
teams engage in pervasive maybe testing
right we know that we could launch two
versions of a website and just see which
one works better and so we learn much
faster where's a traditional shopping
law you can't launch two shopping malls
in two parallel universes and see which
one works better so you just so much
harder to do that we tend to have short
shipping times right you can ship a new
product every day or every week and so
you learn much faster whereas the
traditional shopping mall may redesign
the shopping mall once per once every
three months right and we actually
organize our teams differently we tend
to push decision-making down to the
engineers or engineers and product
managers because in the traditional
shopping mall you know things kind of
move slower and maybe the CEO says
something and then everyone just does
what the CEO says and that's fine but in
the Internet era we learned that the
technology and the users are so
complicated that only the engineers and
the product managers for those who don't
know what that is
are close enough to the technology to
the algorithms and the users to make
good decisions and so we tend to push
decision-making power in Internet
companies down to the engineers so
engineers and product managers and you
have to do that in the Internet era
because that's how you organize a
company or organize a team to do the
things the internet lets you do really
well so I think that was the rise of the
internet um I think we've divided the AI
era or AI machine learning or deep
learning whether you really call it
we're learning that if you have you know
a traditional company plus a few neural
networks that does not by itself
turn the company into AI company and I
think what will define the great AI
teams of the future will be do you know
how to organize your own work and
organize your team's work to do the
things that modern you know machine
learning and deep learning and other AI
things let's you do really well and I
think having many items at Google and
Baidu other buyers I think you know
Google and Baidu like great and
many other countries and thinking the
through but I think even the best
companies in the world haven't
completely figured out what are the
principles by which to organize AI teams
but I think some of them will be that we
tend to I think that AI teams tend to be
very good at a strategic data
acquisition and so you see AI companies
or AI teams even even you know do things
that may not seem like it makes sense
and why do these companies of all these
three products that don't make any money
well some of it is the required data
that you can monetize through other ways
right through advertising or through
learning about users and so there are a
lot of data acquisition strategies that
at the surface level may not make sense
but actually do make sense if you
understand how this can be married with
deep learning algorithms to create value
elsewhere and I think that uh AI
companies tend to organize data
differently right ai teams tend to be
very good at putting our data together I
think before the rise of deep learning
many companies have fragmented data
warehouses where I have a big company if
you have 50 different databases you know
in 50 different divisions it's actually
very difficult for an engineer to look
at all those dates and put it together
to train the learning algorithm to do
something valuable so the leading AI
companies tend to have unified data
warehouses and I guess and I know we
have a large home audience or SCPD or
other home audience here so if any of
you work a large tech companies you know
this is something that that many
companies are investing in today to lay
the foundation for learning algorithms
we tend to be very good at smarting a
pervasive automation opportunities and
which is very good at spotting
opportunities where you could instead of
having people do a task of a deep
learning algorithm to at all so I have a
different thing I offer into a toss and
we also have me
descriptions which I don't have time to
talk about but just as book the rise of
the internet we started creating a lot
of new roles for engineers I think
actually once upon the time the world
was simple and there was just a software
engineering title but as technology
gotten got more complicated we started
to specialize so that's why you know
with the Internet where front end back
and mobile right and then we have you
know and then with increasingly other
roles right cue a DevOps IT move into
increased specialization of knowledge
and so what the rise of machine learning
we're starting the creation of new roles
like machine learning engineer research
machine learning research scientists and
our product managers and AI teams also
behave differently than proper managers
and internet companies and so one of the
things we'll revisit a few times
throughout this quarter is and I don't
mean to to corporate I know that many of
you are you know some of the SUV the
audience or online orders already
working company many of you when you
graduate from Stanford we end up maybe
starting your own company or joining an
existing company but I think that
solving a lot of these questions of how
to organize your team's effectively in
the AI error will help you do more
valuable work and I think to make one
more analogy you know I think that one
of the things I hope Ken and I will
share of you throughout this quarter is
just as in the software engineering
world it took us a long time to figure
out what is agile development right or
whether the pros and cons of you know
waterfall model versus agile or how do
you what does a strum process right oh
this is code review a good idea it seems
a good idea to me right it's but this
these practices after after program
languages were created or invented or
whatever we still had to figure all
these ways to help individuals and teams
write software effectively and so if you
worked in you know high-performing
corporate industrial AI teams using
these software engineering practices
there is an Co review to agile to
whatever you know you know that having a
team work effectively to write software
is more than
everyone knowing C++ syntax are
wondering Python syntax and I think in
the machine learning world we're still
in the process of inventing these types
of processes
what is the strum what does the agile
development what's the equivalent of
code review for developing machine
learning algorithms and I think probably
this class more than more than this
class and machine learning earning more
than any other easels I'm aware of right
now I think we'll try to systematically
teach you these tools so that you don't
just are able to derive a learning
algorithm and implement a learning
algorithm but that you're actually you
know very effective in terms of how you
go about building these systems so last
thing before I pass it can is on the
other question that I've been asked I
guess several times this week now that
just pre-emptive the answer is a so
there are multiple machine learning
classes going on at Stanford this
quarter so the other frequently asked
question is which of these classes
should you take so let me just address
that preemptively before someone else
maybe because I've been asked twice
already and the other two classes is
quarter so I think actually what what's
happened over the last several years the
standard is the demand for machine
learning education has you know been
rising dramatically because I mean years
the majority of CS PhD applicants in
Stanford you know are applying to do
work and machine learning or applying to
do work in AI and I think all of you can
kind of see that there's such a shortage
of machine learning engineers right and
then there's a little bit of and and and
I think that shortage should continue
for a long time so I think many people
see that if you can explain the machine
learning there'll be great opportunities
for you to do meaningful work on campus
to take machine learning to compile or
cosmology on the can train or do great
research on campus as well as Brad from
Stanford and do very unique work when I
wonder around Silicon Valley I feel like
there are so many ideas for great
machine learning projects that exactly
zero people see it through working on
because
just aren't enough machine learning
people in the world right now so by
learning these skills you could you have
many opportunities to be the first one
to do something very exciting and
meaningful right alright and and um you
probably read in the newspapers about
how much money machine there any people
make I'm actually much less more I
actually find that I hope a lot you make
a lot of money but I actually personally
don't find out that you know as exciting
I think that every time there's a major
technological disruption it gives us an
opportunity to remove large parts of the
world and I hope that as some of you go
improve a health care system improving
educational system maybe you know see if
we can help preserve the smooth
functioning of democracy around the
world I think that it really your unique
skills and deep learning will give you
opportunities to do that I think
hopefully very meaningful work um but
because of this massive massive rising
demand for machine learning education
there are some for long time CS 239
machine learning was the core machine
learning class at Stanford's and then CS
230 is actually the newest new creation
I think and the other costs that were
involved in that units and I are
involved in this quarter is CS 229 a so
so if China decide which of these
classes to take I think I think that
these classes a little bit like Pokemon
right you really should collect them all
but better but I think we've been trying
to design these classes to actually
teach different things and not have too
much overlap and so there is so I have
seen students take two classes at the
same time and that's actually fine
there's not that we have old lab is fine
that you actually learn different things
if you take any two of these classes at
the same time 69 is machine learning is
the most mathematical of these classes
and we go much more since through now it
goes much more into the mathematical
derivations of the algorithms CS 229 a
is applying machine learning is much
less mathematical but spends a bit more
time on the practical aspects is
actually easier on Brown to machine
learning as well as the least
mathematical of
classes CS 230 is somewhere in between
this is Monmouth Alden 69 a less Matt
Matthews SCS 230 but where CSU 30
focuses on is a deep learning which is
just one small subset of machine
learning but it is the hottest subset of
machine learning whereas there are a lot
of other machine learning algorithms
from your PCA k-means recommender
systems support vector machines that are
also very useful that I use you know in
my work quite frequently that we don't
teach in CS 230 but then stored in C
it's two three nine six four two two
nine eight oh we're so the unique things
about C's 230 is it focuses on deep
learning so I'll know if you wanted list
deep learning on your resume I guess
maybe this is the the easiest way to do
it I don't know again it's not what I
tend to optimize for but but and I think
CS 230 goes to D pers in their practical
know-how and how to apply these
algorithms oh and so just and I want to
set expectations accurately as well
right so what I don't want is that you
guys did complain in the other quarter
that you know there wasn't enough math
because that's actually not the point
what has happened in the last decade is
the amount of math you need to be a
great machine learning person has
actually decreased I think and I wanted
to do less math and CS 2:30 but spend
more time teaching you the practical
know-how of how to actually apply these
algorithms right so yeah and I think to
2000 a is very the easier this cause
that's the most technical this is the
most most hands-on apply you do a lot of
projects on different different topics
right and I think these courses are
often the foundation or some subset that
these are often the foundational courses
as students say because if you say learn
deep learning some common sequence first
student sister you know learn the
foundations of machine learning or
[Music]
machine learning of deep learning and so
you have the foundation first before you
go which then often sets you up to later
go deeper into computer vision or
national Enders processing or robotics
or deep reinforcement learning and so
common sequencing that common tactic
that Stanford says take is to use these
in the foundation you see a bit of every
thing from divisions national processing
in speech recognition you know touch low
bill on self-driving cars but that gives
you the foundation to then decide you
want to go deeper into the National
image processing or robotics or
enforcement learning or computer vision
or something else this is common
sequencing of classes that students take
ok so um look forward to spending this
quarter with you let me just check out
any quick questions and you're not hand
it over takes you into a decision making
by engineers and product managers you
may be pushing decision making I wrote
this room aching by engineers there but
really engineers and probably managers
Oh a pervasive old sorry a pervasive
automation so to say that like like so
far you like what what are the most like
the most meaningful successes of machine
learning that you think have happened
already so all of you are using learning
algorithms probably dozens of times a
day maybe even hundreds of times a day
without knowing it right every time you
use a web search engine there's a
learning algorithm that's improving the
quality of search results there's also
learning however trying to show you the
most relevant as and this helps those
companies actually make it all the money
every time it turns out that actually
both Google and Baidu have publicly said
that over ten percent of searches on
mobile are through voice search and so I
think it's great that you can now talk
to your cell phone rather than typed on
the tiny little keyboard if you wanna do
a do a web search and mobile if you go
to you know website like Amazon or
Netflix or
there are learning algorithms
recommending more rubber movies on the
more relevant products to you every time
you use your credit cards there's a
learning algorithm kind of probably from
almost all companies I'm aware of does
the learning algorithm kind of figure
out if it's you using a credit card or
if it's been stolen so they should so
they should you know there's a lava see
if it's a fraudulent transaction or not
every time you open up your email
the only reason email is even usable
it's because of your spam filter which
is because of learning algorithm they're
worse much better now than then before I
don't know I and so there's a III think
you know one of the amazing things about
AI machine learning is I love it when it
disappears in the background right you
you you use your you know you use these
algorithms you boot up your map
application and it finds the shortest
route for you to drive from here to
there and there's a learning algorithm
predicting what traffic will be like on
highway 101 one hour from now but you
don't even need to think that there was
a learning algorithm trying to figure
out what traffic will be like one are in
the future seems pretty magical right
that you know but but that you could
just use it this you can but all these
wonderful products and systems that help
people but abstract away a lot of
details so that's the present and I
think in the future near future
most of my PhD students most my research
group here is work on machine learning
for healthcare I think that will have
significant inroads you know and my team
at landing a I spent a long time with a
lot of industries for manufacturing the
agriculture so other things I'm excited
about machine learning for education
keep people precise to tell how people
recommended crew size contents this
fascinating research done here at
Stanford by Chris peach and a few others
on using running errands to give people
feedback on coding homework assignments
I so so sorry there's so many examples
of machine learning I could talk for
quite some time
yeah alright one last question hand over
cancer yeah the C so the so the format
of the class is that you watch videos
created by people and AI
Oh Sarah so you see me a lot there but
in addition Kiran and I will be having
lectures here in this classroom every
Wednesday and that will be you know
completely new material that is not
online anywhere at leas right now yeah
yeah and then also that I think the the
point the point that the flipped
classroom saying really is some of the
things is really more time efficient for
you to just learn online so there's the
online content but what it does is it
leaves this classroom time for us and
not you know deliver the same lecture
year after year but to get other get
spend time to get to know you on they
have more time answer your questions and
also give you more in cost practice on
these things right so there's the
Coursera the vendor course our content
but what what we do in CS 230 is to
augment that to give you much deeper
practice more advanced examples some
more deeper mathematical derivations and
more practice so you know you deepen
your knowledge of that and with that let
me hand it over to the Ken
yeah I'm gonna get back at him by making
noise while he's talking okay okay
thanks Andrew hi everyone I'm John we're
excited to have you here today those of
you who are in class but also those of
you who are CPD students we wanted to
take a little more time to explain a
little bit about the course logistics
what this course is about and also what
it is to be a CS 230 students in fall
two thousand eighteen so the course
online is structured into five chapters
or sub courses let's say what we will
teach you first is what is the neural
you need to know that's after
understanding what a neuron is you're
going to build layers with these neurons
you're then going to stack these layers
on top of each other to build a network
that can be small or deep this is the
first course unfortunately it's not
enough to deploy a network just just
building a neural network is not enough
to get it to work so in the second
course we're going to teach you the
methods that are used to tune this
network in order to improve their
performances this is the second part as
Andrew mentioned one thing we're really
putting a huge emphasis on in CS 230 is
the industrial applications and how the
industry works in AI so the third course
is going to help you understand how to
strategize your project that you'll do
to file the quarter but also in general
how do a AI teams work you can have an
algorithm you have to identify why does
the algorithm work why does it not work
and if it doesn't work what are the
parts that you should improve inside the
algorithm the two last courses course
fourth of course four and five are
focusing on two fields that are defined
by two types of algorithms first
convolutional neural networks that have
been proven to work very well on imaging
or videos and on the other hand sequence
models that include also recurrent
neural networks
that applied the lots in natural
language processing or speech
recognition so you're going to see all
that from the online perspective we use
a specific notation in CS 2:30 so when I
will say C 2 M 3 it refers to course to
module 3
so the third module of improving deep
neural networks okay
and I'd like everyone to go on the
website see a 230 syllabus after the
class to look at all the syllabus
throughout the quarter check when the
midterm is and when the final poster
presentation is the schedule is posted
there so check it out and we're going to
use the Coursera platform as you know so
on Coursera you will receive an invite
on your Stanford email and you should
have received it already for course one
in order to access the platform from the
platform you will be able to watch
videos do quizzes and do programming
assignments and every time we finish one
of these courses so c1 has four modules
when you're at c1 m4 you will receive a
new invite to access c2 and so on okay
inside CS 2:30 we're going to use Casa
as a class forum for you to interact
with the TAS and with the instructors
you can post privately or publicly
depending on the matter okay so let's
see what it is to be one week in the
life of a CSC 230 students so we're
going to do ten times that over this the
Fall Quarter so what is one module in a
module you will watch about ten videos
on Coursera which will be about one hour
and a half you will do quizzes after
watching the videos this is going to
take you about 20 minutes per module and
finally you will complete programming
assignments which are on Jupiter
notebooks you will get cells to test
your code and also submit your code
directly on the Coursera platform in one
week of class in Stanford here we will
have two modules usually on top of these
two modules you will come to lecture for
a 1 hour and a half in class lecture on
an advanced top
that is not taught online and after that
you will have ta sections on Fridays
that are around one hour and it's a good
chance for you to meet other students
for your projects and also to interact
with the TAS directly finally we have
also personalised monitor ship this
quarter where every one of you will meet
15 minutes per week with the TA in order
to check in on your projects and give
you the next steps so we put your huge
emphasis on the project in this class
and we want you you will see it later to
build to the side of your teams by this
Friday in order to get started as soon
as possible next week you will have your
first mentorship meeting with the TAS
okay it's gonna be fun
assignment and quizzes that are part of
modules are due every Wednesday at 11
a.m. so 30 minutes before class so you
can come to class with everything done
and understand it and do not follow the
deadlines displayed on the Coursera
platform follow the deadlines posted on
the CS 230 website the reason the
deadlines are different is because we
want to allow you to have late days and
Coursera was not built for late days so
we we put the deadlines later on on
Coursera to allow you to submit even if
you want to use a late day does that
make sense okay
so we're also using a kind of
interactive this this is gonna start
course to we we will use an interactive
tool that is called multimeter to check
in attendance in class and also for you
to answer some interactive questions so
it's gonna start next next week sorry
not course tone
regarding the grading formula here it is
so you have a small part on attendance
that is two percent of the final grade
eight percent on quizzes 25 percent on
programming assignments and big part on
the midterm and on the final projects so
this is posted on the website if you
want to check it attendance is taken for
in-class lectures for 15 minutes CIA
meetings and for the TA sections on
Friday you can have a bonus and
we've had students very active on on
Casa that answered questions to other
students which was great and they got a
bonus so I encourage you to do the same
maybe we don't need TAS and instructors
there okay so I wanted to take a little
more time to go over some of the
programming assignments that you're
going to do this quarter so that you you
know where you're going in about three
weeks from how you're going to be able
to translate these pictures here in the
numbers that they corresponds to in in
sign languages so it's sign language
trust translation from images to the
output signification you're going to
build a convolutional neural network and
the first villages segregation and then
a convolutional neural network in order
to solve this problem a little later
you're going to be a deep learning
engineer in a house that is not too far
from here called the happy house so
there's only one rule in this house and
the rule is that no sad person should
enter the house should avoid that and
because you're the only deep learning
engine that has the knowledge you're
given this task which is don't let these
sad people in just let happy people in
and you're going to build a network that
will run on a camera that is in front of
the house and that is going to let
people in or not and unfortunately some
people will not get in and other people
will will get in because they're they're
happy and you will save the happy house
at the end of the assignment hopefully
this is one of the applications of the
permeate I that I personally prefer its
called object detection you might have
heard of it so this is running real time
and that's what is very pressing you're
going to work on a deep learning
architecture called Yolo v2 and Yolo v2
is an object detection algorithm that
runs real time and is able to detect
9000 objects as fast as that so it's
it's really really impressive you have a
few links here if you want to check the
paper already but maybe you will need
some weights to understand
okay actually we have a we can even run
it directly on my computer I think she's
going to be fine
oh yeah we can run it so here you see
it's running live on this computer and
so you see that if I move it will find
out that I move so I cannot escape yeah
here it is okay okay a few other
projects one two weeks from now you will
build an optimal goalkeeper shoot
prediction so in soccer you're a
goalkeeper and you want to decide where
you should shoot the ball in order to
make it land on one of your teammates
you're going to find what's the exact
line on the field which tells the
goalkeeper were to shoot two weeks from
now about in the in the fourth course a
convolutional neural network you're
going to work on card detection so this
is a bigger image this is exactly the
programming assignment so you're going
to work on the autonomous driving
application that is finding cars finding
stop signs
finding lights finding pedestrians and
all the objects that are related to Road
features okay this is pretty cool and
you will generate these images yourself
so this is a picture taken from a camera
put in the front of a car and was was
generated by dr dot ai you will have a
face recognition system that is going to
first do face verification is this
person is this person the right person
but also face recognition who is this
person which is a little more complex
we're going to go over that together
both online and in lecture our
generation some of you have heard of
this it's an algorithm called neural
side transfer and again we usually put
the papers at the bottom of the slides
in case you want to check in yourself
for your project but this is a problem
where you give a content image which is
the Golden Gate Bridge and a style image
which is an image that was painted
usually by someone or an image from
which you want to extract the style this
algorithm is going to generate a new
image is going to mix the contents of
the first image with the style of the
second image music generation which is
super fun
you're going to generate jazz music in
the fifth course sequence models you're
going in the same course also generate
text by giving a huge corpus written by
Shakespeare a long time ago of poems
you're going to teach the algorithm to
to generate poems as if it was written
by Shakespeare so you can even write the
first sentence is going to continue and
modify you all have smartphones and I
guess you notice that when you write the
sentence on your smartphone it usually
tells you what you should put next and
sometimes it's an emoji you're going to
do this part you're going to implement
the algorithm that takes an input
sentence and tells you what's the emoji
that that should come after it machine
translation is a is one of the
application that has been tremendously
performing well with deep learning
you're going to implement not a full
machine translation from one language to
another but a similar task that is as
exciting which is changing human
readable dates to machine readable days
so you know let's say you're you're
you're filling in a form and you're
typing a date the the entity that that
gathers this data will have a hard time
convert all these dates into a specific
format you're going to implement the
algorithm that is going to take all
these different dates in different
formats and generate the right format
translate it to human from human
readable to machine readable days and
finally trigger word detection that I
also love and and some of you have have
seen us buildeth algorithm a year ago I
believe which was which unison and
Andrew and I have have worked on trigger
word detection is the problem of
detecting a single word so you know you
you probably have objects from big
companies that detect the voice and
activate themselves under a trigger word
you're going to build this algorithm for
the trigger word activate yeah and many
more projects that you will see now
these are the things that you will all
build in this course every one of you
will be lit through programming
assignments but you also have to choose
your own projects to work
throughout the course and these are
example of projects that CS 230 students
have have built in the past and which
have worked very well
one is coloring black-and-white pictures
using a neural network into the color
representation of these features so it's
pretty cool because we can now watch
movies that were that were filmed in the
1930s or 1950s or I don't know when in
color which is super cool predicting a
price of an object from a picture so
this was a great project in the first
iteration of 6 to 30 where you give it a
bike and then around that 4 it guesses
how much is the bike so if you want to
sell stuff you don't know how much you
just give it then you sell it at under
the price the student had actually
implemented an algorithm to see which
features of the bike are related to the
price so it was super fun to see if it's
the steering wheel or if it's the wheels
or if it's the body of the bike that
makes this bike expensive according to
the algorithm and many more so last
quarter specifically we've had a lot of
projects in physics and an astrophysics
and chemical engineering and mechanics
which was great some examples are
detecting earthquake precursor signals
with a sequence model predicting the
atom energy based on the atomic
structure of an atom so you have you
have for instance software's that run
that are really computationally
expensive that look at the atomic
structure of an atom and will output the
energy of this atom this takes a long
time these students have tried to make
it a three second problem by running a
neural network to find the energy of
yeah - so you have a bunch of problem
across industries so healthcare cancer
parking sonar dimer detection we've had
a lot of these we've had brain tumor
segmentation segmentation is the problem
of on an image classify every pixel tell
me which pixel correspond to the tumor
for example so we were really excited to
see what you guys are going to build at
the end of this quarter and that's why
we want you to build your team very
quickly get started because the project
is what you
be proud of at the end of the quarter we
hope that you guys will come at the
poster session proud of your poster
proud of the final project that you sent
us and you can talk about it in the 10
next years or 20 next year hopefully and
I guess Andrew can-can can confirm that
cs2 to 9 students from the few past
years have done projects that are
amazing today and have been featured
around the world in as a researcher or
industrial project so to sum up in this
course you will build a wide range of
applications
it's very applied there is some math but
less than she has two to nine more than
cs2 to 9a and you have access to
personalized mentorship thanks to the
amazing ta team and the instructors and
finally we will have to build a 10 week
long project so now we we get to the
serious thing what is what we are up to
this week so at the end of every lecture
you'll have one slide that's gonna
remind you what you have to do for next
week next Wednesday 11:00 a.m. so create
your courser account based on the invite
that you receive if you didn't receive
an invite
send it as a private post on Piazza we
will send it again finish the two first
modules of course 1 C 1 M 1 and C 1 M 2
it corresponds to two quizzes and two
programming assignments and around 20
videos ok which are listed here and for
Friday it means two days from now by the
end of the day fine project team mates
and fill in the form to tell us who are
your teammates it's going to help us
find your mentor finally there is a TA
section also this Friday no project
mentorship it would start next week but
we we will see you on Friday I'm gonna
take a few questions to shout about yes
yeah these times we're going to put be
posted at the end of this time
[Music]
so the tail sections we're going to have
a large range of TA section on Friday so
there's going to be basically every time
you're going to be assigned to one of
them and if you want to move you can
send an email as a plat suppose
privately to us to be moved to another
section how big is the same usually it's
from one to three students exceptionally
we would accept a four students if the
project is challenging enough yeah yes
so it is possible to combine the project
with other classes amines been done in
the past what we want is you to to give
a project and a poster that that is
framed as cs2 30 wants it to different
fabula and you discuss with us in order
for us to validate if you can merge this
project with another class because it
requires to have deep learning of course
you you're not supposed to combine this
project with something that doesn't have
the kerning it off
okay all right one more question so you
can you can retake the quizzes as much
as you want on Coursera we will consider
the last submitted quiz for this class
okay so you can resubmit if you didn't
get full way yeah okay thanks guys and
see you on Friday